foreign
[Music]
a wildlife SOS rescue team is responding
to an unusual call from a concerned
farmer
just had a call about a crocodile down a
well wow I know it is it is freaky weird
right
but that's that's India for you
the crocodile situation in madagara is
Extreme
we've got this big bustling City
and right through it a crocodile
infested River
then during the monsoon rains
the waters rise so the crocodiles
literally come into the streets into the
villages
and you've got crocodiles and people
living on top of each other
have you guys done many crocodile
rescues in in Wells before you know what
it's quite unusual isn't it yes
sounds like the beginning of the joke
how to get the crocodile of the well but
we're about to find that out
oh yeah the road ends here
yeah yeah
you're the one who called us yeah
is this where the crocodile is yeah
that's really high
it's much bigger and much deeper than I
was thinking this is like an abyss
I have a little funny thing with Heights
literally I feel nauseous
there's no signs of any crocodile
so we have a ticket of some photos and
videos can you show me yeah yeah take a
look at that uh yeah there is but he's
not a full-grown adult he's a juvenile
that looks like a meter no I'm saying
forfeit
the monsoon flooded this entire area and
that's how the crocodile ended up at the
bottom of the well
is been living here since and if you
don't remove it it's going to be trapped
down there forever
as soon as he gets bigger he's not going
to survive anymore he said he's got to
go back to the wild
the problem is that we do have water
down there
and we don't know how deep the water is
could be two feet to 10 feet
let's get a net ropes hardness lights
let's go get the gear and come back and
come back yeah let's do it
[Music]
back at the wildlife SOS sanctuary
an urgent calls come in from a worried
member of the public
has been attacked in one of agra's busy
neighborhoods
we got a call there is an injured monkey
yeah it's bleeding why is it bleeding do
you know dogs were trying to attack him
that sounds like it could be really bad
yeah it could be all right well we
better get there fast
we are upsetting the Natural Balance of
things
because they don't have good Garbage
Disposal Systems thousands of monkeys
and feral dogs live in Indian cities
what happens is that you have a lot of
competition over food and it can lead to
a lot of aggression between monkeys and
dogs
[Music]
so bhaji do you know where it is I
really don't know but we can ask the
caller
hopefully it's in this area because they
do have a habit of getting away from it
that is the issue
so this gentleman saved him from the
dogs
oh we have just started moving because
people had Disturbed him yeah and they
had gone on to the wall and moved on to
that building we have to move very
carefully otherwise he's going to run
away
there he goes
we need to go up
this got complicated fast
monkeys are never easy and today is no
exception
he's fast
oh my God
he doesn't have any hands
he's climbing up this old apartment
building he just has stumps
the most likely way that he lost his
arms was grabbing onto an electrical
wire
I think we're gonna have to just get
this done because he's going to keep
moving away I'm guessing he should not
jump over the building
we're gonna try and catch him the
problem is if this monkey gets too
nervous and panics is going to jump
right off the building and he'll jump to
his death
ly difficult situation now we are into
yeah this is not ideal so you and hatam
can be here
I'm going to go up
uh hatim and I are staying one level
below so that if the monkey jumps down
one level we'll be ready for him
I can see him I can see him
well I see blood all over this monkey
we're gonna have to rush him to the
hospital because
[Music]
he's bleeding pretty profusely
name
foreign
yeah okay stay calm he's actually moving
towards you now he doesn't know which
way to go you have a chance to get in
there now
yes
okay he's got him name name
okay he's in the net we've got the cage
come on
well done guys thank you
oh he's in horrible shape yeah he's
Savaged by dogs he has very bad dog bite
it is bleeding you may have to carry him
fast let's get into the hospital yeah
that was crazy there's a second there I
totally thought he was gonna jump right
off that building
it looks like he's been bitten in the
armpit here he's got really big vessels
there
budget who's actively bleeding out of
his neck here yeah we should put on our
siren and get there
[Music]
in the west of India
the wildlife SOS team is preparing to
descend the well
I'm worried about the safety of the
people we send down there to find this
Croc it's trapped it might feel
defensive and snap at someone
the worst thing that could happen is
that we've underestimated the size of
this Croc all we can see is like dark
murky water there could be a man-eater
down there we have no idea what we're
dealing with
this is a very critical
find out what the depth of the water is
but you have to be very careful so we
cannot take any chances here
first sign of danger you just say pull
and and we'll pull you guys out good
luck okay
so we want to make sure that when the
guys go down the climb
it's gonna be really really sturdy I'm
going to use a center point to lower the
guys down the well
here we go
you can kneel down now and climb over
the edge okay go ahead
gently
keep going
so tell me when he's one-third please
he's one-third stop there okay well see
my you ready
going over now
careful okay okay Carter yeah stop
this makes me nervous because really I'm
looking out for two people here one in
each rope so it's quite a responsibility
both of you are going to start going
down gently
go slowly
slowly slow guys
okay just reached the bottom okay and
this is very very dangerous
very confined space the crocodile could
actually leap out of the water and
easily snap at any of their feet
okay if I seem a little little bit more
those guys are right at the water's edge
right in the strike zone
what is that we'll get
it yeah whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
the wildlife SOS team is descending a
60-foot deep well we got you we got you
we got you
to rescue a stranded crocodile hiding
beneath the surface
well Seamus hit the bottom okay so where
is this crocodile
look at every crack every little crew is
in there
this is a very dangerous situation we've
got to be extremely careful and get
these people out alive
can you see anything yeah so what do you
see in the ever seen
oh my God that looks like a pigeon chip
it's the main source of the protein for
the crocodile because there's no signs
of any crocodile
the water we don't know how deep it is
can't see through it it's too dark
and we'll have to come up with the
strategy of getting this water out
before we can find the crocodile
okay listen guys we are going to bring
the bamboo stick which is measured up to
12 or 13 feet
guys watch out
we're sending this bamboo down
okay loading it
loading it
okay we've marked off every foot on that
from 1.5 feet onwards start with your
end machine
push it down and see
okay
oh my God it keeps on going
10 feet deep oh my God
this is a huge problem that is not what
we expected we were told it's two and a
half feet possibly so we now probably
have to get a generator a pump and pump
out some of this water and capture the
crop
pull them out and then get the pump yeah
okay we'll see him first let's get you
out of there okay let's pull keep
pulling
we're almost at the top we got you okay
excellent
oh man well done well done thank you
good job fantastic
how are you feeling down there oh yeah
it's suffocating down there because it's
a close piece yeah difficult to breathe
in there if you stay there for too long
your hair starts spinning
a lot of people would say this was a lot
of effort to go to for one crocodile but
I say no pain no gain you know if you
want to help that animal do what's
required to make it happen thank you big
hand to me fish
we brought a pump in and the idea is
just to drain the water down and
overnight hopefully in the morning
there's going to be a crocodile down
there waiting for us lower lower go
in
Can you feel it there it is
let's come back in the morning
back in Agra the wildlife SOS team
arrives at the animal hospital with a
critically injured monkey
hello doctor
very very difficult condition just
bleeding because dogs bit him very badly
I'm really worried stopping the bleeding
is definitely our first priority we lose
the hemostatic injection so that will
minimize the bleeding okay
we're gonna put a little uh
hemostatic drug on the wound on his neck
close off the blood vessels and try and
stop the bleeding
he's too awake to be handled safely so
we're going to have to sedate him and
then we can do a proper physical exam
it's been three minutes since injection
and now he's he's down
I'm going to take out this yeah
[Music]
looks like the bleeding from his neck
has stopped
but he's lost quite a lot of blood I'm
fearing we're going to find some some
pretty extensive injuries
so he's been ripped open here by the
dogs actually it's good they missed the
brachial plexus which is full of very
important nerves
since this is
it that's correct these are dog bites
um and they're so full of bacteria that
if you suture it closed you basically
keep the infection in there so we're
doing an iodine scrub
we're cleaning this extremely well
we're gonna have to clean out all the
puncture wounds or he is gonna go septic
that's basically like a bacterial
injection you get that tooth going all
the way down in there and it's just
injecting bad bacteria into that area
really deep down
more you clean the more problems you see
you get two teeth marks right there one
two that's where he they just grabbed
hold of them right there we need to get
the bacteria out of there otherwise it's
going to fester and uh and kill them
eventually so I gotta get that really
really clean
I think that's good
so now it is completely clean
we cleaned out those wounds really well
but that could lower his temperature so
we're just going to check that make sure
he's not becoming hypothermic
102.9 103
he's hyperthermic his body temperature
is up at 104 Fahrenheit if it keeps
climbing up then we're really in a
critical Zone
he's failing to regulate his body
temperature which basically means like a
full system shutdown
with really high temperatures like that
you can cook your brain
he's burning up it's not good he's
really burning up get the ice packs yeah
ice packs put it between his legs
cool them down that's okay do you want
me to prepare Sub-Q fluids yeah get the
bottle
So Butterfly catheter 60 ml syringe this
is life-threatening
the temperature is the main is the main
concern actually at the moment
he's he's burning up
uh yeah sure okay
so we're gonna do everything we can to
cool them off
there we go
there you go
Dr Raja is going to put an intravenous
line in we're going to run cold fluids
into hip
101.4
I think what we're doing is working yeah
it's becoming cooler
so we've come down two degrees
he's gonna be okay
is it very difficult for you to see
things like this every day
it's emotional
torture to us place for animals are
Getting Thinner and thinner where they
can't survive now anywhere
we're just blowing up the ecosystem
everything some things are shooting up
some things are going down
one of the best things that we can do to
help him maintain his body temperature
is actually to reverse the anesthesia
when he's under anesthesia you're kind
of suppressing all of those life
functions
we have to just put him into the cage we
don't want any other struggling with him
or giving stress to him when he wake up
he should be in the cage
poor guy
okay I feel really bad I didn't realize
how overheated he was
sad
he's struggling he's recovering slowly
the most dangerous part of anesthesia is
the recovery if you're going to lose an
animal under anesthesia often it's on
recovery phase when you think that
you're actually out of the woods
it's not waking up like expected I'm a
little concerned about him now we will
see I don't know I don't know exactly
what is going to happen to him it's
really sad
a normal healthy animal would have been
sitting up 25 minutes ago
maybe we didn't act fast enough
at the wildlife SOS Animal Hospital
a monkey Savaged by feral dogs has
survived surgery
but is now fighting to recover from the
anesthesia he's not recovering normally
it's really sad
we shouldn't be feeling bad because we
have tried our level best
I was waking up
wow
okay good oh God
it is very very nice
good job everyone
yeah
[Music]
it's a great great job good job you guys
I'm feeling really relieved because I
was feeling really guilty that we hadn't
acted fast enough and that he might pass
away we shouldn't we we are always doing
our best for the animal sometimes it
depends on fate as well
I mean he lost his arms due to probably
due to electrocution at some point then
he couldn't move away from a pack of
dogs fast enough
he climbed four stories to get away from
us in the heat he developed a really
severe fever as a result of it
you know he's a big strong boy and he
wants to live
thank you Dr Raja thank you thanks for
your family help
too much
when he started to move around and sit
up that was such a really
out in the city is a bit risky for him
because he can't climb very fast and he
doesn't have hands
so we're going to give him a home here
at the sanctuary
he'll be safe here he'll make some
friends here
[Music]
thank you
having pumped the well overnight the
wildlife SOS team is back to check the
water level and hopes to find the
stranded juvenile Croc
oh wow wow that's excellent oh whoa I
can see the crocodile in there yes yes
it was in the water yes
so we finally got eyes on the Croc all
we can see is his head it's um looks to
be this size maybe but boy
I'm a little bit nervous I'm not sure
how we're gonna do this
it worked it worked and I have a case of
crocodile flu and I've lost my waist but
it's worth it if you can find the
crocodile
ready now if we can actually send our
team down and bring the crocodile up
leading the rescue team is expert
crocodile Wrangler Mr Raj
the wall is of not good
there is some hole inside the brakes
some gaps so if any emergency pull up
pull up okay
can you guys move to the side
because Mr Raj is coming down
feet down and walk against the wall okay
we're over walk down the wall yeah
you're good okay bye halfway there good
you okay hurry up two-thirds away there
okay almost there yeah
where'd that come from
there's all this debris branches trees
maybe thick sticky mud so we're gonna
have to be really careful whoa whoa whoa
pull it up
we got you
is that good yeah okay
that was a close one and he wasn't
attached to this rope he would have
fallen back into the water
you okay Mr Rush yeah I'm fine all right
now we got all three men down there
safely
each One's Gonna Get a catch pull
something to catch crocodile with at the
same time a defensive weapon in case
crocodile decides to have a goatum
Mr Raj what are you seeing nothing right
now nothing he's hiding
being an ambush Predator crocodiles can
stay underwater for long periods of time
they sit still you don't know they're
there but by the time you do it's too
late
whoa careful careful careful hold
whoa whoa whoa
keep tight keep tight keep tight keep
tight
the mud is too thick and there's too
many branches it's too dangerous
Rooney's just taking his shoes off now
better grip must be so slippery down
there
this is an extremely critical situation
crocodiles have the strongest Jaws in
the world and once they clamp on it's
almost impossible to get them off all
right let's do this boys use the board
and stir up the bottom
I'm trying to disturb him
see he's doing the death roll now
he's trying to he's trying to bite the
cash ball pull it up pull it up pull it
up
the wildlife SOS team is struggling to
restrain a cornered crocodile
is fighting
Spin and go underneath the branches
Pockets looking pretty tired now
we got it
we have pep and we have caught a
crocodile so we have now removing from
the water he's a juvenile he's young
we've manners to get it out of the water
we've covered its eyes so the Croc is a
little bit disoriented
the plan is to get control of that mouth
the dangerous part
crocodiles have some of the greatest
bite strength of any animal measured and
any bigger you're talking dinosaurs here
we go
careful careful careful
we got it well done
Raj has that bottom yellow rope he's
going to pull against it keeping the
crocodile off the wall so we don't
injure on the way up nice and slow keep
on going keep on going that's good
[Music]
thank you Mr Raj we got it we got it
whoo
this is great he's in pretty good body
condition he could be a little bit
stunted in growth it's a possibility if
he's only been on pigeons for the last
few years but if he's only four or five
years old and he looks good
but now that the crocodile is out here I
am hugely relieved because this animal
can now go back to where it belongs
[Music]
back at the wildlife SOS Sanctuary
volunteer vet Dr Hessian Holt is helping
to revamp the animal enclosures
it doesn't look like vet work but
actually having a really good
understanding of animal husbandry is
really important for wildlife vets
especially if you want to manage a
sanctuary
oh it looks like an animal intake
[Music]
what are these These are Jackal pups
golden Jackal yeah you rescued from a
nearby Village
jackals are a medium-sized dog-like
animal that are distantly related to
gray wolves
they punt and scavenge after dark and
they play an important role in the
ecosystem
in areas where there's agricultural land
they're really important for rodent
control
so you couldn't find parents no parents
was not there yeah no so that's why he
bought them here and these guys are
really young probably only three weeks
old they would have died without their
mom
let's go check how these guys are doing
thanks so much
I gotta wash the paint off my hands here
[Music]
let's check it whether they are okay
the main concern would be that they're
dehydrated but yeah yeah actually
she's got a very moist nose and bright
eyes yeah it's nice and moist well
that's great that maybe we got there
just sort of in time should we try and
get a few calories into these guys
if you can't get a baby animal on milk
within 24 hours you're in a life or
death situation they get dehydrated and
they get low blood sugar incredibly
quickly
for the first weeks young Jackal pups
actually stay in the den and the mother
goes out and hunts for them but Mom is
not around here and I know these guys
need to eat something
[Music]
from here
this is definitely a two-person job
we found a safe spot
and they're going to stay there till
their mommy comes and gets them
all right Cutie Pies
I apologize
we want this note to be exactly the
right temperature and that'll help
convince them to drink it because this
is going to taste different than their
mother's milk
let's just
is that food are you gonna eat it
this is the small female but I am
concerned she's definitely underweight
she's the one who actually needs the
sugar the most if you want to try it
with the syringe
not too fast
oh wow that's awesome she's almost
latching on that's definitely what we
want
great
[Music]
puppies are messy
Karen I'm having trouble getting these
guys to uh
drink the milk they're really not
recognizing it as food
it doesn't taste like Jackal milk it's
not exactly the right consistency you
know it's a China plate it's not natural
they're used to being in a den in a
really dark environment so I'm making
some Corners in the blanket so they have
somewhere to hide so they feel like
they're safe they're much more
comfortable when there's something above
them there we go good puppy
so does each of them get enough to eat
we're gonna put them one by one back in
the basket
nice excellent
[Music]
that is what we want
until 10 well they're super fan of the
flavor and the texture but they are
drinking it and that is the main thing
no you all done
plan for tonight is to try and reunite
these puppies with a mom
thanks kidding
just look for a den find a suitable
place to put these guys and hopefully
arrange a reunion
[Music]
in the west of India the wildlife SOS
team is looking at a potential release
site for the rescued crocodile
[Music]
foreign
lots of Crocs down there oh my God
there's almost a dozen of them
see some Big Fellas up there this River
it's Unique because it kind of goes
through the city it's a fascinating
landscape because people live cheek to
Joel by these crocodiles right it's
shocking
I'm noticing a lot of dogs here look at
that
that's probably what they're feeding on
there's a dog coming near the Crocs now
he has no idea who he's walking into
it's literally surrounded by a rocks
if you get within a body length distance
of a Croc they can launch and have you
in a second
and now that the dogs turned around and
got the better of it
you know this can be a potential spot to
possibly release let's go take a closer
look
at that sign
it says beware of getting down into the
river because it has a nests of
crocodiles and you will be in Mortal
Danger
this is not advice for everyone but we
have to find a release site we're gonna
have to be careful we're kind of Walking
Into the Danger Zone over here we watch
the water constantly
there's a Jawbone of an animal
this is one that didn't make it
this is nesting season they're going to
be really defensive if we come across
the nest
I'm seeing a lot of Crocs here
we have a bit that are dense all along
the that's the thing hang on
so happy to see this Den
it shows they're thriving this is a real
privilege but at the same time you know
I'm a little bit scared
[Music]
she's looking at us
I think I think we're on top of our den
right here yeah
I think the den
does mean that there's crocodiles I'm up
right up here where we are
if we get much closer she is going to
have a go at us it's not going to be a
bluff charge she's gonna she's gonna
come at us for real
careful
in the west of India Paul and kartik
have found themselves between a mother
crocodile and her Den there's a tin
right there right behind us
when I saw that Den my heart was racing
the reality set in this this is real
if that was a close one
fighting those bins in the riverbank was
exhilarating
it is a great piece of news
so these cockras are breeding
there's such a healthy population in
this River it's amazing
they all seem to be in really good body
condition they're not fighting over food
they seem to be happy
I think this is a good place to release
the crocodile back where it belongs
[Music]
foreign
a wildlife SOS team is heading to a
remote Village
to reunite The Jackal puppies with their
missing mother
[Music]
a place that we're headed is a farming
area
for them I mean it would be fantastic if
we could find a dentist yeah they need
the mother
I really hope we can make this work we
have to try
[Applause]
laughs
so do we have the exact location where
they were
yeah
okay this is the place where he found
the pups
so maybe we should start walking like in
a spiral away from the spot and see if
we can find it then okay
[Music]
this is where Karen beer found the puppy
so there should be a jackal Den
somewhere nearby but I don't imagine
it's going to be very easy to find
jackals are very adaptable they can be
found in short grasslands dry arid
country in nature these guys would be
hidden in a den a comfortable little
hole in the rounds it's going to be
surrounded by leaves and grass
[Music]
I feel like I'm a lot more likely to
find a snake here than a jackal then
it's gonna come back for her pups it's
going to be at this time of day so
this is our window
it's not too hot
just around evening time
she only lost them this morning so I
mean she
if she's alive she's going to come back
to this area I hope we find her
you see Anthony
that's amazing that you found that
and in the wet dirt here
we have jackal
footprints
we had rain two days ago it's very
possible that this Den actually flooded
maybe that's why the mother abandoned or
was trying to move her pups
you think the best chance of reuniting
them with their mom would be in front of
the old Den yeah
go back to the vehicle and we'll get the
puppy here
hopefully we once we put the pups in
there then that's it we back off and we
don't
yeah that's the plan okay she might be
afraid to approach the pups
she might have moved on she might have
been
hit by a car
I don't know I really I really hope
that we can get a reunion with Mom that
would be amazing
okay so time to place the pups here goes
nothing
and then here's our little girl so if we
put them all in there this is perfect I
hope they stay there so this is the
perfect time to get the mother back pops
are inside the den and now we can move
from here okay okay yeah
so we've put them back at their old Den
we're gonna hang back
worry that these pops because they're
starting to get hungry are gonna go
wandering and get lost in the Dark Khan
view is doing his very best to keep
track of them with the binoculars
unfortunately we have to do this because
we absolutely have to give them a chance
to get back together with their natural
mother
[Music]
the wildlife SOS team has been trying to
reunite a litter of Jackal pops with
their missing mother
[Music]
but last night's attempt has failed and
the jackals have been taken back to the
sanctuary
last night was really disappointing we
had our fingers crossed for a reunion
but Mom didn't turn up at all
some of the people in nearby Village
reported having seen some tents and
thought there might have been poachers
in the area
jackals are hunted or poached in India
this is for their pelts which are sold
on the black market
but it's completely illegal under the
Indian Wildlife protection act
there's not much hope at this point of a
reunion so these guys are going to have
to be raised here at Wildlife SOS
they're pretty opportunistic feeders
they'll scavenge
so these guys still have a good shot at
living in the wild
[Music]
today we're going to build them an
enclosure where they can have really
minimal contact with people
but we're going to check on them
they're on a strict feeding schedule you
know insects veggies fruit and we're
gonna provide them a lot of that stuff
in that enclosure
over the next couple of months we'll try
and expose them to as much natural
stimuli as possible
so when they're finally released it's
not this huge shock for them
nice
find and smell and chew on it's interior
decorating but for jackals I've always
been a big fan of shabby chic which you
know everyone knows that jackals are
also fans of
these guys really need a safe place to
grow up together so I'm really hoping
that they take to this Den right away
time to investigate your new dins
I'd like them to feel comfortable in
here
they don't like this basket anymore
that's for sure
I'm pretty excited to see what they do
[Music]
this he's really exploring
oh my goodness he's smelling all it
smells
this is awesome
all this nature look at you
they're playing they're falling down
they're going to gain strength by
walking around and climbing things
these Jackal pups are loving this new
enclosure you can tell they are so happy
to be out of that basket this is a big
day if you're a jackal pup
I think this is going to be a really
nice safe place for them to grow up
they're already really enjoying it and
they have a great chance of survival
[Music]
in the west of India a large crowd is
formed to watch the release of the
rescued crocodile
beautiful creature she is love to meet
your soul
yeah
says Juju means
this is a great opportunity for us to
educate the local community is when they
see that something's not a threat and
they see that it's something that
belongs with them and they're not
terrified
help protect it
we're attracting crowds there's just
people everywhere they're really excited
it's time for release
this is the river you found earlier
there's lots of crocodiles they're doing
really well it's as good as it can get
where are we going up or down down down
what do you think about it Croc no funny
movements he is already thinking it's
just amazing to be near such a criminal
and powerful animal
these guys are the ultimate survivors
they've outlasted the dinosaurs by 65
million years
[Music]
okay
ready
[Music]
freedom
[Applause]
he just like disappeared very smoothly
giving it its freedom it's worth all the
pain to be able to see that animal go
back where he needs to be
for the first time in years this
crocodile was able to swim freely that
was beautiful to be a part of that
[Music]
thank you